Parliament elected Ursula Fonda Lyon as  president of the European Commission  with 383 votes out of 733 she will be  the first woman to hold the post members  voted to set up 44 inter parliamentary  delegations delegations work with  parliamentarians in other countries to  promote EU values and exchange  information in June see watch three  rescued more than 40 migrants and its  captain was arrested after going against  Italy's orders not to dock mep x'  discussed the e use divisions on helping  migrants at sea at least seven children  have died in u.s. border control custody  since December 2018 MEP is called on  both Mexico and the u.s. to comply with  human rights law  Finland outlined the priorities of the  rotating EU council presidency the union  should be a global leader in climate  action and push for carbon neutrality by  2050